[Music]
[Music]
it's so great to be back in peace
mansion
yeah it's it is nice to be back we
became like
master chefs last year we did yeah we
became a couple a couple of ramses
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh
you know sean evans coming this year
dude i [ __ ] love sean
me too but like he
he [ __ ] us up he did yeah he [ __ ] us
up he [ __ ] everybody
he [ __ ] everybody
whoa whoa whoa
yo should we get him back i think that's
i think that's that's where uh i was
trying to take this conversation like
what do you think we should do i think
we should just like we should just
give him a taste of his own medicine
[ __ ] his ass up brian who the [ __ ]
brings a toothbrush to a party i know
what a [ __ ] weirdo
what is wrong with him looks good
yeah it looks good it looks good
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me
where's this green juice yeah i think so
it's so [ __ ]
weird healthy what are you guys doing
with my green
juice
um i'm keeping an eye on you guys
yeah i'm rich brian and i'm joji last
summer we became master chefs at the ada
rising summer mansion
and this year we're teaming up with even
more chefs and special guests and asking
a few of our idiot rising label mates to
help us out
to the freeze mansion welcome to the
feast mansion
welcome to the freeze mansion welcome to
the feast mansion
hi this is joji this is british brian
and you are watching the greatest
cooking show in the world yet again
peace mansion yes and uh the last season
we became really
great chefs chefs like the best chefs of
our generation but [ __ ] ramsay
but there's one thing that we still
haven't conquered
and that is pizza pizza we don't know
how to make pizza we're gonna need some
help
and today we have international pizza
consultant anthony falco and her great
friend
sean evans
oh are you ready brothers yeah let's
make some pizza
i'm ready i'm amazing i'm going to party
hey guys thanks for having me i'm hyped
to be off the fridge this time around
i'm glad to be here at the feast thank
you for coming so yeah greatest big
interesting show in the world
the greatest honor yeah in cooking
gordon ramsay
and um bobby flay they called me and
they were like yo like can we be on the
show i said
no dude that's yeah you can't their
pizza sucks
yeah oh yeah yeah so you're not only a a
pizza
pizza chef but you are a consultant yeah
yeah i fly all around the world and help
people open pizzerias
yeah it's pretty sweet i have one more
question
pineapple on pizza what's that to you
highly divisive
issue pineapple is just a fruit that
originated from south america
just like tomatoes people don't really
do a good job of it so like i have a
technique
okay that i may or may not have already
prepared for tomorrow
i'm just saying if you want to spread
that
amazing so like pizza should always be
fun just use good ingredients
don't overthink it and make it something
that you can recognize as pizza like
don't try to get too fancy
are we making fun pizza today yeah
totally that's all i know how to do
right
i'm just like mr fun pizza that's my
whole yeah yeah that's
awesome so i thought it'd be fun to make
uh some fresh mozzarella like make our
own mozzarella oh yeah
all right let's [ __ ] do this
this is mozzarella curd it's what this
is so we've got our curds salted now and
what i'm going to do is pour
hot water over them so i'm pouring on
the side because i don't want to scorch
our little baby curds and we're just
going to kind of move these back and
forth
in the hot water and you can see they're
starting they're starting to come
together
the proteins are starting to interlock
in the um
in the presence of the hot water and
there's milk fats are
trapped inside of these these proteins
that are called caissons
and inside the milk fats yeah and so we
want to keep that as those
those fats trapped in there so we don't
want the water to be too hot but we
don't want it to be too full
the whey has already fully been
separated but we don't want the water to
be too hot but we don't want it to be
too cold or the curds won't
form just water pretty hot so it's going
and i want to get all of it together
so there's no like little loose guys
floating around anymore then i'm gonna
dump this water out
so you guys who wants to give this a
stretch right is it hot
it is hot as [ __ ] but that's what the
paddles for but get you get your hand to
touch it and then kind of get under
there and lift
yeah and then you can see like kind of
get all the way under and then go
up whoa dude i feel like brian's a
natural in the kitchen
am i actually thinking brian yeah brian
cookson you're pretty lucky i appreciate
it even like something you've never
tried before
you should give this a shot don't be
afraid touch it yeah exactly
that's your technique right there good
boy that's it yeah and then it goes
nice and slow i like that that's good
yeah dude pro stretch right there
calling it
yeah it's a natural you wanna give this
a try yes
the cheese rifle
this looks like teeth oh you wrapped it
up that's
that's a that's a dope look all right we
got i think we have plenty of
mozzarella to make some pizza so we're
gonna pull out the dough
i'm gonna make an actual pizza all right
guys
let's do it let's do this hell yeah
[Music]
all right we have our our does here
they've spent
three days kind of doing their thing and
slumbering and
fermenting yeah it's a long slow
fermentation
way i like to roll you want to have a
little bit of flour but not too much so
you can work it
yeah the first thing i'm gonna do is
kind of create the crust by just kind of
dimpling
everywhere that i don't want crust and
the whole process we want to be really
gentle with our little dough babies
but i'm just going to dimple it really
quickly and then go to the bottom
and a little more flour on the bottom
i'm going to just rub it in i'm gonna
pick it up
kind of go back and forth a little bit
and then you can put it in your hands
like you wanna support it you don't
wanna have like a fingertip and this is
some real pizza
that is fantastic yeah and that's how
you do it it's really easy you guys are
probably going to be like
really good at that no really i don't
know
see what you guys can do and at any
point you feel
like we're freaking
it's not surfing you just stop
oh that's too much flour joji time out
time out
okay so you guys can now give it a shot
of trying to throw in the air i mean
it's up to you it's kind of an advanced
level thing
and you might kill your pizza
there you go all right now don't go
yeah maybe just a couple that joji what
are you have you no i've never done this
you've never been kidding
whoa all right mama mia bro bro here we
go
wow sorry john you've improved
thank you i appreciate it last time we
made pizza together joji very excellent
brian
i like how you just kind of stayed under
the radar and we're like
that was really fun though that's good
and so yeah you want to just this is
your bottom
yeah and you just want to give it a
little bit of flour rub it down and like
this is ready to make into a pizza
[Music]
so this is our dough it's like the right
size and stuff
so we're going to use these california
tomatoes we're in california
so that's good they're local what i'm
going to do now is going to put some
basil in here
i'm going to do some of this fresh
mozzarella also a little bit of shreddy
kind of american style mods on here too
i'm gonna open up my um
oven here and just
boom it's set to about like um
8.50 well 750. let's say 750.
and i like to give it a little spin so
the heat is nice and even on the crust
and i don't really like time it or
anything i just kind of use my eye
peepers i feel you yeah and just you
know go from there
we're calling it that's it damn yeah it
doesn't
it looks pretty good that's really good
boys oh
look at that look at that ass that was
great whoa
it looks like a picasso painting it's
got like char on it it's like
it's not neapolitan it's something this
is american this is
it's california this is peace man cpk
this is
cheers cheers cheers cheers
yeah cheers
that's what i came here for
this is pizza no lie is excellent it is
really
nice it's really good i'm going in for
now really good tomatoes sometimes when
i eat pizza i feel really unhealthy but
this time like i'm just
yeah i mean we saw how it was made is
that too bad exactly
i like that it's not just the fresh mods
too there's that kind of like
american like nostalgic like stringy
yeah aged moss really good i think it's
good it's the best pizza i've had i
think i still can't believe we just made
this
nothing better than just hanging out in
the kitchen with your guys
yeah taking pizza bites getting major
cheese pulls
just you know ford bros making pizza
very hot very strong pull
amazing pizza
[Music]
dudes that was like a super classic
delicious simple
pizza cheese pizza great cheese pizza it
was [ __ ] crazy we're in california
where
california pizza was invented and like
really took pizza to some uncharted
territories
crazy toppings you guys want to try to
make some
let's make some weird pieces yeah if
it's not getting weird then
let's get weird right that's like that's
kind of thing to do
let me go get some toppings let's do
this yes sir
[Music]
guys thanks so much for having me on the
show i know at the feast mansion it's
all about pushing culinary boundaries so
i thought it might be fun
if we made a hot sauce yeah okay i like
that i like the idea do you know how to
make hot sauce
i've done it before i've done it before
we push it on hot ones as you guys know
but i've been scorched out
i've been scorched out i need to
reinvent the wheel we need to make a hot
sauce that even halle berry can respect
so noah from heatness he sent me these
ingredients okay here we can mix it up
but i've got
habaneros all right i've got sambal oh
i've got garlic
szechuan peppercorns oh no i think you
just layer it
so all right what is that it's like a
layer a little mustard
mustard oh whoa
pop the garlic in is that essential oh
there you go put all that [ __ ] in there
the whole thing it's actually kind of
cool because we have the peppercorn
from china and then we have the yuzu
from japan
which is where georgie's from and then
we have sambal which is where i'm from
it's like all just combining our
cultures together and mixing it in this
culture in this cauldron
i mean this is this is pretty innovative
but coming together
it is coming together but i do think we
should
add like we should we should kick it up
a notch a little bit okay um
no criticism just i just think right
i've like since we are
doing this like i wanted to kind of
oh like we can [ __ ] start here why do
you have that with you what is that
because i'm a [ __ ] chef brian
i'm sorry anyways
we got some [ __ ] lobster this is um
one of the face huggers things in the
prometheus you ever seen prometheus
these are [ __ ] these are some eggs
they're my eggs just mine
this is the octopus it was actually
charles darwin's pet
um from 200 years these are just fish
bits from the inside of fish
it just died it was the longest living
they actually had a tortoise that died
maybe like 12
years ago but this is um charles
darwin's octopus that was
fermented um these these are crabs um
and like there was like a lot of plastic
with it but like i'm not too worried
about it
is when tom cruise was in japan and he
was the last hammer from charles
darwin's octopus that was
fermented and saved um really well
carl's gone
visited japan once joji i was skeptical
at first but this is really coming
together something's happening for sure
i've done my fair amount of uh cooking
that's like really going huh
that was i think i think it's right it
looks like we're almost done yeah
i might have to
oh [ __ ] tits
[Music]
dude we made a hot sauce i told you yeah
i told you
what should we call this thing
what the
dragon in the clouds dragging in the
clouds
dragging in the clouds
[Music]
foreign